we got the story from wired I'm gonna
make this one quick for you guys so you
can get angry as fast as possible the
bird flu outbreak has taken an ominous
turn the avian flu has killed millions
of chickens decimated wild birds and
moved into mammals the avian flu h5n1
has a mortality rate in humans of about
60 percent and if we go back in time to
this article from February 8 2019 we can
see that they were doing gain of
function research intentionally making
it so that h5n1 would transfer to
mammals
there you go how are you guys doing wait
a second what wait take that back so
they were doing gain of function
research to see if avian flu would
translate into matter no no no it does
they were doing gain of function
research to make it to do it on purpose
to mammals so they're intentionally
trying to kill us and destroy our entire
food source at once they're they're
saying it's so that they can learn about
what happens when it infects humans oh
my goodness and their damn intellectual
inquiry I mean come on is that what it
is is that what you think it is
intellectual inquiry yeah sure they
think that's what it is I'm not
convinced you don't think the scientists
think that's what they're doing I do not
believe that someone's like I'm very
curious as to what will happen if I take
the one of the most deadly flu variants
I want to hear it bioweapon research
this is bio weapon research yeah this is
the first thing I thought when I
actually saw the China balloon was what
happens if we do shoot it down and it
has a bio weapon in it boom avian flu
look at this in 2011 Fuji and kawaoka
alarmed the World by revealing they had
separately modified the deadly Avian
h5n1 Influenza virus us so that it's
spread between ferrets Advocates of such
gain of function research blah blah blah
we can learn so much about it critics
are worried that the super virus could
spark a pandemic if it escaped the lab
or was intentionally released by a
bioterrorist I don't think it makes
sense to be like what's a very deadly
strain let's modify it so that it
infects mammals to learn about it this
is enough to become it's bio weapon
research
is it is it gain of function or is it
like evolutionary
literally they're literally science
science.org in 2019 called it gain of
function research and now we're learning
the h5n1 spread from birds to minks
which are similar to ferrets and they
had to kill all these mink in in Spain
or whatever if it jumps to humans it is
a depending on your source of 40 to 60
mortality I think wired said it was a 52
percent uh what is it science medical
journal of some sort I pulled it up
earlier this morning said 60 mortality
so you could use gain a function to
create a bioweapon you could use vent
gain a function to create something
that's not a bio weapon you could how
did you describe what you thought this
was uh intellectual inquiry yeah I'm
sure you could do intellectual inquiry
on something that is create also a
bioweapon and intellectual inquiry or
something it's not this obviously could
be weaponized the World Health
Organization abandoned their Research
into the origins of the covet virus this
week that was funny yeah they were like
no we don't care anymore no we're not
going to look into that this reminds me
of the 2015 study that was of the the
covid variant that they were doing in
other places in the world you know so
this very well could be something that
we see in the Future come out as another
pandemic like I see you setting up
dangerous situations to practice
overcoming dangerous situations like
let's let's set a house on fire and have
the firemen go in and put the fire out
that's what firemen do sometimes
and so you're but they don't set fire to
someone's neighborhood yeah and they
don't say let's direct the meteor into
Earth to see how we will overcome if a
meteor falls into Earth you use computer
simulations for that stuff so the bio
weapons I think you we should be using
Quantum Computing but of course the
government sets fire to neighborhoods
like in Philadelphia and what like 86. I
think I think this is uh I think bio
weapons have made nuclear weapons
Obsolete and the discussion around
nuclear weapons I hate this whole
concept so much this bio weapon thing I
mean isn't it totally against the Geneva
Convention
who cares about the conventions are
nonsense the idea of war crimes are
nonsense the idea that you as a nation
want to seize land from another Nation
but you better follow the rules yeah
right so where nobody who's actually
fighting a war cares about the rules so
now we're in a position where we have to
trust machines to drive us around but we
can't trust each other to make
agreements without being total Liars
that's always been the case we're gonna
have to really not agreements when we
start don't you watch out no I don't
watch Yellowstone I'm watching it the
Native Americans are like this woman she
says the United States makes makes rules
against everyone that it conquers they
say hear the rules they break those
rules then set the rules again hoping
you won't break them
yeah that is a little bit what happens
but
um
wait you trusted other people at any
point
that's the craziest part to me did you
trust the government at any point in
time I don't think I trust the
government but
um but you have to trust other people
otherwise you have absolutely no comrade
chip and you have absolutely no one you
can confide in yeah I trust people who
are close to or care about totally of
course I trust some people I don't
necessarily trust people that are saying
hey let's just like mess around with
these really deadly passes no no no I
mean but you know I think
um I think I had assumed that you could
trust your allies like International
allies to not totally destroy the world
yeah yeah but then you know the US did
just blow up Germany's pipeline so hey
allies attacking allies that's not
pretty yes the British obsession with
keeping Germany and Russia separate when
the German Russo Alliance comes to
fruition I mean if you look at it it is
because
Britain nearly got bombed off the face
of the Earth
I kind of think it's a strong
possibility we will see some kind of
future pandemic like like this one at
first it's going to take out all the
animals
and then if you live in a city they're
gonna they're gonna lock you down and a
government truck will pull up at nine in
the morning to hand you your daily food
allotment of the bare minimum calories
you need to survive all the morbidly
obese people will become gaunt and
skinny everyone else who's used to not
eating too much will probably just
starve to death no they won't starve
they're gonna be given food from the
government and you're going to be given
an allotment and then it's going to
dramatically reduce carbon and they're
going to say oh well you know it's the
bird flu this kind of sounds like what's
happening in East Palestine
right yeah chemical release but I mean
people are walking around their chickens
are just dead and they're foxes foxes
are dead yeah cause I'm like why would
someone want to destroy this awesome
planet and what we've got but then I'm
like ah I'm talking from my perspective
as an American like if you saw the
Hunger Games way too though like why
would you want to destroy everything and
humanity is so beautiful because you
know did you see the Hunger Games no I
don't know the villains in The Hunger
Games that's I think how the world looks
at people like the gluttonous people of
the United States that's no that's how
people look at the world economic Forum
I mean have you seen how Klaus Schwab
like dresses
Star Trek outfit wait are the villains
just super preppy they got like huge
hair
yeah and put it next to eating or puking
and like they're overeating for fun and
and
they don't even know about what's going
on outside their City I did not see that
outfit what it's great but he's like
Romulan yeah he does look around Dylan
right yes okay this guy dresses like a
super villain what's up yeah that is a
super villain outfit what is this
I think he's playing the part yeah he
likes it he likes the attention yeah I
think he's controlled
to kill the people
he's the figurehead that's being
controlled by everybody else though you
think so yeah he created the economic
Forum which is basically a nothing
Burger but then all the people around
Earth start to take it seriously and now
he's they're propping him up as long as
well just look at everybody that invests
into World economic forum and you see
who's controlling the money and who's
controlling everything else like the
Gates Foundation that has their hands in
everything so does the the Chan
Zuckerberg Foundation going all the way
even into like SEL in schools they're
controlling all that stuff too well
there's a crazy thing with sel2 where
the teachers are so hyped on SEL and
that they figure that they don't
actually need to teach kids anything
other than the social emotional stuff
because they've said that the emotional
quotient score is more important than IQ
score that's why yes and it's just not
true I mean I have to say like my son
was in a public school that was super
SEL that was all everything was he would
come home and he'd be like Mom you know
this is what I did in social studies and
it's all social emotional learning and
now he's in a school where that's
definitely not the focus and his grades
have gone up dramatically is this
something you've been focusing on so
what is it exactly social emotional
learning so that's it's it's taking the
well-being of the student into account
well over the like what they're actually
being taught in school to make sure that
they're more intelligent and so like
that's what you're seeing a lot of even
like the queer Theory and stuff like
that being pushed into schools because
they want to make children more
comfortable in their in their classroom
settings and more manageable yeah and
actually even like so I've mentioned
Zuckerberg they have a um an app that
they're coming out with it's called
Panorama Ed and when you use this app
it's basically a social credit score for
students you look you see a student when
they do something good you give them a A
plus and when they do something bad you
give them a negative and that is
basically becoming their permanent
record as they go through school I'm
saying it sounds like an ESG for kids
it's all tied in and there's all these
like surveys you know it'll be like
asking you about how you feel about
everything and there's constant
interference in interactions between
kids and adults are constantly telling
kids how to play how to interact with
each other how to think about you know
how to think about things they're not
teaching them facts they're not teaching
them you know anything about their
history it's really disturbing to see it
and it's disturbing to see the impact on
kids because they just get very like
sort of it's the system is set up to
follow them because it's SEL and grade
schools and through high school and then
you have Dei diversity Equity inclusion
in colleges and then you have ESG and
and you know corporations and so it's
basically
um what is it conditioning them to
accept these these systems and we've
been conditioned with credit or credit
scores for so long I was looking at my
credit I'm like wait a minute so they
want me to take out three credit card or
take out a bunch of credit cards and
have a little bit of debt on every
credit card so I'm paying a small
pittance to the company of of interest
every time and they're good slave we'll
give you a better score on your credit
score because you paid us your interest
every month yeah sure and the more debt
I'm paying every month on these multiple
to different organizations that's you're
more ingrained in our system
congratulations good good credit is
built up by having debt that's correct
your credit does not improve if you have
no debt and that is the that's the they
want you in debt and then they give you
a reward for it within this this guys
yeah I have this argument with my mom
years ago because I had had student loan
debt and she was like you have to pay
off your student loan debt and I was
like it literally doesn't matter it's
perfectly fine debt I can die with this
debt it just doesn't matter if I ever
pay it off as long as I pay them you
know whatever it is based on whatever
their metric
it doesn't matter if it never goes away
as long as you're paying me in paying
paying like whatever it is and then you
do it forbearance here and a like
adjustment there and a re Readjustment
of your interest rate over here it
doesn't matter it just doesn't matter if
people should be able to bankrupt that
off like George Bush Jr made that change
that so you couldn't go back bankrupt
your student loans off your off your
well and then college degrees became
worthless because everybody you know
everybody was getting them and now
they're they're not worth it and that's
well and that's why they're so expensive
too because they've taken out the
capitalistic aspect of it so you can't
go bankrupt because the government will
pay it either way or actually the
government will always get their monies
back so because everything is
government-backed that's why you can't
go bankrupt on it right and that's why
tuition goes up because it's a bunch of
free money yeah so the kids can just go
get more and more free money exactly so
just go get more and give it to us yeah
I I consider doing bankruptcy you guys
ever do bankruptcy before I consider
doing it in like 2013 because my credit
was trash and I didn't I just
default that on all my credit cards and
after seven years it's all gone my
credit's good now so like don't be
afraid of debt don't be afraid of it so
what I found out oh go ahead well what I
found out is if you change your name
some of the credit scores don't update
that and if they sent you letters in the
mail you don't have to respond and if
you do respond they'll be like okay now
he's back now we got to get him now he
owes us again yeah I literally had this
conversation with TransUnion yesterday
because they still hadn't updated my
full credit score after I changed my
name
I've had uh fake things sent where is
that yeah it's like you I was smart like
I got a letter saying it was like a
couple hundred bucks that was owed from
this company I'm like I don't know that
and they're putting a mark on my my
credit score or whatever and I call them
like I don't know this you're wrong dude
I had this one situation I had Bank of
America I had a thousand dollars in the
bank and some I sold my magic card to
someone they paid me with a check via
Craigslist terrible move never do that
so I went I cashed a check they gave me
1500 immediately I spent I like no money
in my account I put the 15 in I spent
900 of it and then the next day they
were like oh the check bounced they gave
me a negative 1500 put me at negative
900 and I was like yo yo yo I'm a
customer and you sold me that fifteen
hundred dollars when you cash that check
you can't go back you sold that to me as
a customer and the girl was like I know
I know they did but you're a negative
900 nothing I can do about it amoral
cancel my account
if they cash your check and they tell
you that that check is cashed as I think
you have a right legally to that money
was the check of Bank of America check I
don't remember so like when you sign up
for a bank account you're you you agree
that you are cashing a check against
your balance
maybe that's the case I don't know but
but I will also add they make a certain
amount available then but that should
not be legal because I didn't ask for a
withdrawal if the check that you cashed
is no good that's on you
if I wanted to with to withdraw money
from my account why would I cash a check
well they shouldn't make it available
instantly yeah they mean they're going
to screw you over after if it's no good
I think that making it available
indicated that the transaction was Final
in my opinion yeah I think you're
correct
but there's very little banking
regulation that protects consumers
against uh you know Bank manipulation
I mean even overdraft fees is like how
do you have an overdraft fee when they
allow you to go into the negative that
makes no sense right they give you the
money and then charge you for it yeah
and it's not even a third normal
interest rate No it's like just super
that's that's the joke that if you're
poor they charge you money but if you're
rich they give you money for free yep
yeah that's like that metric song which
one uh I forget which one it is it's on
Art of doubt I think but it's like I'm
so rich everything's free
uh all right what's happening
I guess we're all just tired of being
ripped off by lying politicians lying
scientists lying scientists pandemics
line Bankers gain a function research
and we've consumed too many black pills
you guys want to sit in silent
meditation for 10 minutes I feel like we
should all just take one of these
chakras dude one day we're gonna do a
show where we just meditate for 30
minutes and everyone's going to meditate
with us the world yeah viewers would you
meditate with Ian for 30 minutes give me
a 20 door I was very excited about that
he was like you actually do that yeah
Bad Morning Show like hey wake up with
Ian thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time